nocturnal animals as directed by Tom
Ford and stars Jake Gyllenhaal Amy Adams
Michael Shannon and Aaron taylor-johnson
and is three narratives combined into
one to tell a very complex story in the
present day Amy Adams plays an artist
who receives a manuscript written by her
ex-husband played by Jake Gyllenhaal she
begins to read this book and then we
visualize her reading the book and we
see that story played out and we also
flashback to the past to see how Amy
Adams and Jake Gyllenhaal originally met
and so we have three stories combined
into one this is a very unique movie in
a very unique way of telling its story
Tom Ford is well known for being a
fashion designer but also has shown
himself to be a pretty good director in
the past with the film a single man here
I think he outdoes his work in a single
man and makes his best film yet I think
nocturnal animals is a very different
and unconventional film I admired this
film quite a bit for its visual look and
the appeal of its leads Amy Adams is
very good but Jake Gyllenhaal and in
particular Michael Shannon are
incredible in this movie I thought
Michael Shannon was amazing and Aaron
taylor-johnson is so creepy in this
movie that he genuinely got under my
skin I actually didn't enjoy watching
him at times and that's just praised for
his work because he's supposed to be
repulsive and he definitely he succeeded
in portraying that if you're the type of
audience member that enjoys a film that
causes you to think afterwards that
makes you want to go back and see it
again through a different viewpoint
films like this years a rival or enemy
strangely enough both films with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Amy Adams then I think
you're really going to appreciate
nocturnal animals because the first time
I saw it I was like that was really well
directed extremely well acted very tense
and I really enjoyed it but as I began
to put more thought into it in the
various visuals that Tom Ford utilized
in this movie I began to realize how the
three story lines really interconnect to
make a deeper film that I initially
thought it was while I was watching it
because once you begin to connect these
three storylines and see how they all
work towards a bigger whole the film
takes on a far more different meaning
than when I initially saw it and then I
thought
about it more and it just became one of
my favorite films to think about over
the past few weeks see I really like
movies that have a deeper philosophical
meaning that can leave you feeling a
little ambiguous that can make you think
more about the film than when you were
actually watching it those types of
films that stick with you are rare
nowadays and nocturnal animals is to be
praised for being a movie that is brave
enough to be strange and very different
it's opening credits alone I flew yeah
there are times though where Ford is a
little sloppy and delivering his deeper
themes in this film to our moments where
it's literally written on the wall for
us and sometimes that can come off a
little heavy-handed and there are
moments in the film where it feels a
little pretentious as you begin to
connect certain visual cues that
happened in the past with the storybook
part of the film also with the present
part of the film and sometimes it all
doesn't necessarily come to a cohesive
whole there are some unanswered
questions which is to be expected in a
film that is highly highly metaphorical
like nocturnal animals is but overall I
respected this film for its great
performances its amazing visual look and
then it's ballsy enough to be a big film
with big actors that's weird and
different
that's rare nowadays I'm gonna give
nocturnal animals and a - so yeah if you
couldn't tell this cold I've had is
still really kicking my ass hopefully I
get over it soon guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]